from the time I became an astronomer I
dreamed of winning the Nobel Prize yet
now 25 years after becoming a
professional astronomer and even after
nominating the winners I've come to see
how humanity skillet of award actually
impedes scientific progress 300 years
before the first Nobel Prize Galileo
opened a new window on the cosmos when
he first turned a small telescope to the
sky Galileo's observations shook up the
world overthrowing the paradigm that the
earth was the center of the universe but
even Galileo had his own share of
astronomical blunders he mistook the
dust clouds he sawed in the beautiful
Pleiades for the combined glow of
innumerable other stars Galileo's
telescope saw visible light but to see
the Big Bang requires a different method
the oldest light we can study is called
a cosmic microwave background the
leftover heat from when the universe was
a mere 380,000 years embedded within
this cosmic glow may lie the imprint of
something much older primordial waves of
gravity from inflation which occur just
a split-second after the midnight in
2005 my colleagues and I set out to
detect these disturbances we did so from
the coldest darkest place on earth the
South Pole using the bicep2 telescope in
2014 the bicep2 team shocked the world
claiming that we'd witnessed the spark
that ignited the Big Bang the world
erupted in applause and whispers and
Nobel Prizes as well but there are other
impostor signals that can mimic the
signals from inflation he's come from
dust clouds from our own Milky Way
galaxy soon after our announcement
rumors began to spread that bicep had
been mistaken had we seen the birth of
the universe or had we like Galileo
before Ben
what role does the Nobel Prize play in
the motivation of scientist today how
does the Nobel Prize fail to live up to
Alfred's lofty visions and how can it be
reformed losing the Nobel Prize explores
the complex conflict between passion and
greed collaboration and competition in
the pursuit of humanity's highest honor